[Aplausos]
i
si pudiéramos un sonido
miraremos el color de cada armónico que
le acompaña
y que le hace existir como sonido
como música
[Música]
un sonido
viene acompañado de muchos sonidos que
aunque no los escuchemos existen
nosotros escuchamos la suma de todos
esos sonidos en uno solo
los escuchamos
escuchamos un solo sonido pero sentimos
todos
eso significa que la música desde su
esencia nos enseña que nosotros mismos
somos la suma de una serie de procesos
que se suceden de manera simultánea
somos la suma de sensaciones de
sentimientos de alegrías de tristeza de
sentimientos encontrados
anaïs nin decía que la música es capaz
de derretir y unir todas las partes de
nuestro cuerpo
que están separadas
yo diría que además de nosotros estar
compuestos por líquido estamos
compuestos por frecuencias sonoras por
resonancias y si esas frecuencias
sonoras nosotros las estimulamos
estamos estimulando nuestra creatividad
y estamos abonando el camino para ser
más sensibles espiritualmente
en fin yo diría que la música nos vuelve
a conectar con nuestra esencia
esto pienso yo después de muchos años
dedicado a la música
incluso
debo confesar que mi carrera musical no
comenzó sino de manera autodidacta mi
recuerdo es que lo vivo el primer día
que me regalaron un 4 venezolano pero
les digo el cuatro venezolano es
parecido al ukelele incluso es más
hermoso
me puse a sacar acordes desesperado
música para que para irme de serenatas
con mis amigos para irme de fiesta para
alegrar fiestas
así comenzó mi carrera por la música
con alegría
todo lo que aprendí lo aprendí a través
de una algarabía de sonidos de acordes
de ritmo de baile eso era una
experiencia extraordinaria
extraordinaria
recuerdo con la noche
un amigo guitarrísta unas pesas de esas
muchísimas noches de serenatas un amigo
guitarrísta viene acompañado de un
violonchelista
cuando yo escuché el cello por primera
vez quedé hechizado hechizado
eso hizo que mi rol de serenatero diera
un brusco giro a mi formación como
músico profesional y como músico formal
por fortuna
esa transición no fue tan dura porque
justo el profesor de violoncello mío
el primer profesor de violoncello fue
precisamente esa persona que nos
acompañó aquella noche de serenata y
supimos nosotros unir la rigidez la
rigurosidad de las primeras lecciones
del violonchelo
manteniendo las noches de serenata
inicié mi carrera
en el conservatorio de mi ciudad natal
luego me trasladé a caracas allí comencé
el nivel medio de música finalicé mis
estudios allí luego me trasladé a
inglaterra a terminar ya mi carrera
superior de música especialmente en
dirección de orquesta
todo lo realice en conservatorios de
hecho actualmente los conservatorios es
donde la gente termina estudiar su
música y termina su carrera musical pero
sabían ustedes para qué fueron creados
los conservatorios
a raíz de las cruzadas en italia de las
pestes de las guerras se crean los
hospedales
uno de ellos fue en los pedales de la
pieza
donde antonio vivaldi era uno de sus
maestros
los pedales de la pieza y me quiero
centrar allí un momento porque quiero
darles mi opinión sobre la palabra
piedad yo pienso que la piedad debe
estar relacionada con el deber que
tenemos todos todos absolutamente todos
de ayudarnos especialmente en las
situaciones más difíciles
superarlas y lograr nobles objetivos
no me gusta relacionar la piedad con la
lástima y la compasión
en los pedales de la puerta
se usaba la música como un medio de
transformación
como un medio de realización personal
y todo esto trajo como consecuencia la
mayor muestra del arte y de la mayor
condición que se puede esperar de un ser
humano traducidas en que traducidas en
orquestas en grandes coros conformadas
por virtuosos por grandes cantantes
personas que tenían en la música como su
razón de ser como su foco de atención
como su manera de primero de
autorrealización de autotransformación
de transformación a los demás y por
supuesto de transformación
a esa sociedad
poco valor creo yo
que a veces le damos a la música a pesar
de estar siempre presente en nosotros yo
creo que no le damos el valor necesario
en el mejor momento de la enciclopedia
soviética define a la música como la
variante del sonido hecha por personas
es el sonido del universo ese sonido de
la naturaleza ese sonido de los árboles
de los pájaros nosotros lo hacemos
nuestro
nosotros lo convertimos en ideales en
sentimientos en la vida en la vida misma
todo ese vasto mundo sonoro que nosotros
construimos da espacio a niños a jóvenes
adultos ancianos
disfruté mucho mi infancia
y mi juventud en venezuela gracias a la
música
y hoy
desde mi madurez como director de
orquesta veo lo importante y el gran
valor orgánico que tiene la música como
un medio de transformación
es impresionante
gracias a la música yo he sido testigo
de ver un coro de 5 de 15 niños verlos
cómo se transforman en una orquesta de
un centenar de chicos que hacen levantar
de sus asientos al público que les
escucha y saben que no solamente los veo
que se levantan porque aplauden lo que
tocan sino que también se levantan su
espíritu eso
eso es una cosa muy importante
además he visto como hay chicos y chicas
que trascienden sus circunstancias
difíciles a nivel personal
y no solamente ellos se ven beneficiados
sino también se ven beneficiados sus
familias y todo el entorno que le rodea
es
para mí considero yo hoy yo soy un
director de orquesta social un servidor
de comunidades
yo a través de la batuta intentó hacer
una simbiosis entre la música y las más
altos y los más altos valores de la
condición humana
yo yo creo que vuelva a repetir que no
le damos la importancia a la música que
le debemos dar si todo el tiempo está
sonando si todo el tiempo nos está
acompañando todo el tiempo es esto esto
es impresionante
yo pienso
y quiero
y decirles ustedes que quizás
quizás me equivoqué pero seguro que cada
uno de vosotros ha escogido un tema
musical y se ha adueñado de él y lo ha
convertido en su banda sonora
esto es así
yo hoy
les invito
a que miren la música desde otro punto
de vista con otro con otro valor
no tengo oído no canto yo no tengo ritmo
eso es mentira
nosotros incluso en este silencio
nosotros estamos sonando somos ritmos el
universo es ritmo totalmente incluso
cuando estamos dormidos respiramos
acompasados
y los que ronca mos ronca moss también
acompasado lo digo con orgullo
me recuerdo
que el violonchelo fue
mi primer paso fue mi herramienta para
descubrir el mundo de las orquestas
yo recuerdo que tuvimos un encuentro uno
de esos tantos encuentros que se hacían
de orquestas juveniles en venezuela no
sé si ustedes han escuchado eso el
nombre de las orquestas juveniles de
venezuela y un día nos embarcamos en un
autocar y nos vamos aún a la capital de
venezuela caracas y allí entró a un
sitio inmenso parecido al palau sant
jordi
y entro y hay una orquesta casi de 500
músicos
impresionante
recuerdo que me siento me pusieron un
número porque nos teníamos bien
identificados a todos una camiseta con
un número
me senté y hacíamos el primer movimiento
de la quinta de beethoven datos
que el primer movimiento de la quinta de
beethoven lo podemos entender como tres
notas ta ta ta ta
como la llamada del destino recuerdo que
ese día vi a una persona que se montó en
el podium con una energía y una visión
muchísimo más allá de cualquier visión
de futuro que podamos tener nosotros ese
era el maestro josé antonio abreu él me
enseñó
que la música y la vida son una sola
cosa
fue mi primer maestro de dirección de
orquesta
y como a muchos
nos ha marcado y nos ha influenciado de
cómo vemos el fenómeno musical
cuándo
ustedes salgan de aquí
además por favor de ver la música de
forma diferente
no sé si se recuerdan cómo comencé la
charla
la comencé diciendo que un sonido venía
acompañado de muchísimos armónicos
y ustedes cada uno
son armónicos de esta sociedad y os voy
a pedir que reflexionen y que miremos
como sumamos cada uno de nuestros
sonidos
a esta música de nuestra sociedad como
los sumamos y hacemos una música llena
de oportunidades
de actividad positiva
porque esos somos somos armónicos
les invito a que saquen de dentro la
música que tienen dentro
recuperen vuestra esencia
y permitamos todos vivir
y sonar cada vez más juntos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí